[Music]
my name is Chuck Robbins and a senior
scientist with the Center for coastal
studies here in Provincetown
Massachusetts I direct the humpback
whale research program here which is a
long-term study of humpback whales a
multi-decade study primarily in the Gulf
of Maine here but also in other parts of
the world for example in American Samoa
in the past and Hawaii and other areas
basically we're identifying whales based
on the ventral flute patterns that's why
we don't recognize it as a whale that
we've catalogued before nor as a whale
that we biopsy sample before and that's
why it's important for us to get a
sample today this could be a yearling
that was born last year and we just
simply didn't see the whale with its
mother so we're seeing it for the first
time and most likely it sits in the 1 to
2 year range this
it's the sample or the darkness we pull
it out of the water and as you can see
there's place what stick out here so
just a little bit of lever and all that
we have to do is screw this there's so
many bacteria there that even if we take
a few off there will be plenty for
analysis okay at this point we don't
have reliable health assessment
techniques for humpback whales what we
really need are more systematic and more
quantitative methods and my hope is that
the work that Amy's doing ultimately
down the right will provide some of
those indicators for a backwards
you
you